f of x is equal to 7x minus 5.
g of x is equal to x to
the third power plus 4x.
And then they ask us to find f
times g of x So the first thing
to realize is that this
notation f times g of x
is just referring
to a function that
is a product of f
of x and g of x.
So by definition, this notation
just means f of x times g of x.
And then we just
have to substitute
f of x with this definition,
g of x with this definition,
and then multiply out these
algebraic expressions.
f of x is right over there.
And g of x, is right over there.
So let's do it.
So this is going to be
equal to-- switch back
to the orange color.
It's going to be
equal to f of x, which
is 7x minus 5
times g of x, and g
of x is x to the
third power plus 4x.
And you could-- we're
multiplying two expressions
that each have two terms.
You could use FOIL if you like.
I don't like using
FOIL because you
might forget what
it's even about.
Foil is really just using the
distributive property twice.
So for example, you
take this expression.
Whatever you have out here,
if you had a 9 out here,
or an a, or an x, or anything.
Now you have 7x minus 5.
If you're multiplying it
times this expression,
you would multiply this
times each term over here.
So when you multiply 7x
minus 5 times x to the third,
you get-- I'll
write it this way.
You get x to the third times--
actually, let me write it
the other way.
You get 7x minus 5
times x to the third.
And then you have plus
7x minus 5 times 4x.
And now we can do the
distributive property again.
We're not normally
used to seeing
the things we distribute
on the right hand side.
It's the same exact idea.
We could put the x to
the third here as well.
And when we distribute,
you multiply
x to the third times 7x
and times negative 5.
is 7x to the fourth power.
X to the third times negative
5 is minus 5x to the third.
And then you do it over here.
You distribute the
4x over the 7x.
4x times 7x is plus 28x squared.
4x times negative
5 is minus 20x.
And let's see if we
can simplify this.
We only have one fourth degree
term, one third degree term,
one second degree term,
and one first degree term.
Actually, we can't
simplify this anymore.
And we're done.
This is the product of those
two function definitions.
This is f times g of x.
It is a new function created
by multiplying the other two
functions.